Liebe Leute, wenn ich mir so eure Kommentare
anschaue, dann habt ihr ein ganz schön großes
Problem!
Deswegen werden wir heute über Blattläuse
sprechen und da werde ich dir vier Methoden
an die Hand geben, mit denen du den Blattläusen
Herr werden kannst, deinen Garten endlich
zurückeroberst gegen diese Heerscharen von
Blattläusen, die da gerade bei dir einfallen.
Aber bevor wir mit den Tipps loslegen, sprechen
wir erst mal über Blattläuse an sich.
Es ist nämlich ganz klug als Gärtner zu
wissen, zumindest ganz grob, wie die sich
denn im Garten ausbreiten, was die überhaupt
wollen und wann sie schädlich sind und wann
nicht.
Natürlich sieht es erst mal schrecklich aus,
wenn die ganzen Pflanzen voller Blattläuse
hängen.
An sich ist das aber erst mal gar nicht so
ein großes Problem, denn Blattläuse nehmen,
wie alle Tiere in unserem Garten, eine Rolle
in unserem Ökosystem ein und sind für die
Pflanzen gar nicht so schädlich, wie man
meinen mag.
Natürlich saugen sie an den Pflanzen und
schwächen die Pflanzen damit, aber mit einem
geringen Blattlausbefall kommen die Pflanzen
schon noch zurecht.
Was manchmal problematisch ist, ist, dass
Blattläuse Krankheiten übertragen können.
Also es ist auf jeden Fall sinnvoll, etwas
gegen Blattläuse zu unternehmen, aber kein
Grund, in Panik zu verfallen oder das Gärtnern
zu verfluchen, wenn auf einmal so viele Blattläuse
bei dir auftauchen, denn das ist ganz normal,
das ist kein Weltuntergang und da kannst dagegen
etwas unternehmen, sodass dein Garten hoffentlich
bald wieder viel hübscher aussieht.
Bestimmt hast du schon einmal beobachtet,
dass manche Blattläuse Flügel haben, während
andere keine Flügel haben.
Das passiert immer dann, wenn es den Blattläusen
nicht so gut geht.
Wenn zum Beispiel viele Marienkäfer in deinem
Garten unterwegs sind, die ja Blattläuse
fressen, dann reagieren die Blattläuse ganz
smart und die nächste Generation hat dann
einfach Flügel, sodass die vor den Marienkäfern
wegfliegen können und neue Pflanzen aufsuchen
können.
Oder wenn zu wenig Platz auf der Pflanze ist,
wenn es der Pflanze nicht so gut geht, dann
entstehen eben diese Blattläuse, die fliegen
können und die dann eben losschwirren und
noch andere Pflanzen in deinem Garten oder
in der Umgebung befallen werden.
Und so breiten die sich dann in deinem Garten
aus.
Das ist eigentlich ziemlich clever von denen,
oder?
Also ganz egal, wie viel Ärger Blattläuse
einem bringen, sie sind schon faszinierende
Geschöpfe und ich finde es immer ganz spannend
zu beobachten, was die denn eigentlich so
treiben.
Viele von euch wissen wahrscheinlich, dass
Ameisen sich Blattläuse als Honigkühe halten.
Das heißt, die gehen zu den Blattläusen
hin, die verteilen um die Blattläuse drum
rum einen Stoff, der sie benommen macht, damit
sie eben nicht wegfliegen und schön dableiben,
wo sie sind, weil die Blattläuse eben einen
Zuckersaft absondern, den die Ameisen total
gerne trinken.
Und die Ameisen gehen sogar so weit, dass
sie den Blattläusen die Flügel abbeißen,
damit sie nicht abhauen können.
Ganz schön fies eigentlich, ist ein bisschen
Sklavenhaltung, oder?
Aber dafür beschützen die Ameisen sie eben
auch und fressen zum Beispiel Marienkäferlarven
oder töten die zumindest, ich weiß nicht,
ob sie die dann auch essen, damit die nicht
die Blattläuse auffressen.
Also es ist schon so ein bisschen eine Symbiose.
Aber wenn man mal so genau hinschaut, ist
es schon, ja, eine Form der Sklavenhaltung,
findet ihr nicht?
Ich würde deswegen jetzt nicht so weit gehen
und Ameisen töten, die in deinem Garten unterwegs
sind, wenn sie jetzt nicht noch auf andere
Art und Weise riesige Schäden anrichten.
Aber was du machen kannst ist, wenn du einen
Ameisenbau findest und du siehst, die sind
ständig an den Blattläusen und beflügeln
das Ganze auch noch, also sorgen dafür, dass
deine Pflanzen noch weiter von den Blattläusen
befallen sind, dann kannst du den Bau ausgraben,
in einen Blumentopf bringen und irgendwo in
eine weit entfernte Gartenecke umsiedeln,
sodass das möglichst nicht mehr passiert.
Aber viel mehr würde ich gegen die Ameisen
nicht unternehmen, weil die ja auch sehr nützliche
Funktionen im Garten übernehmen.
Vielleicht interessiert ihr euch ja einfach
kein bisschen für Blattläuse und was die
so den ganzen Tag treiben und wollt einfach
nur Tipps haben, wir ihr die denn jetzt endlich
loswerden könnt.
Und da fangen wir einmal mit einem Tipp an,
der langfristig wirkt, aber eben sehr wichtig
ist.
Und der bedeutet, dass du deinen Garten so
gestalten solltest, dass Nützlinge, also
Fressfeinde der Blattläuse, auch in deinem
Garten ein Zuhause finden.
Die Blattlaus hat ganz, ganz viele Fressfeinde.
Ich muss da jetzt einmal auf meine schlaue
Liste schauen, damit ich die alle zusammenkriege.
Das ist einmal natürlich der Marienkäfer,
dann Schlupfwespen, Gallmücken, Schwebfliegen,
Florfliegen, Raubwanzen, Spinnen, Käfer,
Ohrenkneifer und sogar Vögel- Also das sind
allesamt Nützlinge, die sich entweder von
den Blattläusen ernähren oder sie als Wirte
für ihre Eiablage nutzen und damit, ja, eben
auch zur Dezimierung der Blattläuse beitragen.
Und ein naturnaher Garten, in dem es vielleicht
auch mal einen Laubhaufen in der Ecke gibt,
in dem es eine Trockenmauer gibt, in dem Hecken
sind, in dem sich viele Tiere wohlfühlen,
in dem es vielleicht auch Totholzhaufen gibt.
Auch Insektenhotels sind natürlich eine tolle
Möglichkeit und sehen vielleicht ein bisschen
ordentlicher aus.
So ein Garten ist natürlich super, um all
diese Nützlinge in deinen Garten zu locken
und damit kannst du dir so viel Arbeit sparen
im Biogarten, indem du einfach darauf achtest,
dass das, ja, nicht ein reiner Nutzgarten
ist, sondern eben auch ein Lebensraum für
alle möglichen Insekten und andere Tiere,
die sich in deinem Garten ansiedeln sollten,
damit sie dir so lästige Feinde wie die Blattlaus
vom Hals halten.
Aber auch mit Mischkultur kannst du eine Menge
erreichen.
Ihr wisst es, ich bin ein riesen Fan davon,
Beete in Mischkultur zu bepflanzen.
Das heißt, Pflanzen nebeneinander zu setzen,
die sich entweder Schädlinge vom Leib halten
oder Krankheiten vom Leib halten.
Und da gibt es einige Pflanzen, die du super
gut in deinem Garten anbauen kannst, um Blattläuse
fernzuhalten, das sind vor allem Kräuter.
Und ich pflanze die super gerne in meinem
ganzen Garten einfach entlang der Wege in
die Gemüsebeete, da habe ich super gute Erfahrungen
mit gemacht, denn Kräuter, vor allem diejenigen,
die ich euch jetzt gleich aufliste, haben
ja oft einen sehr aromatischen Duft, der Schädlinge
fernhält.
Und gegen Blattläuse hilft vor allem Bohnenkraut,
Thymian, Oregano und Lavendel.
Das sind ja alles Kräuter, die man sowieso
gerne anbaut, oder?
Ich meine, Thymian ist so ziemlich das tollste
Kraut überhaupt, das esse ich total gerne,
davon kann ich gar nicht genug haben.
Und wenn das dann eben noch die Funktion erfüllt,
den Garten vor Blattläusen zu schützen,
dann nichts wie her damit und ab in die Gemüsebeete!
Das ist echt eine super tolle Sache und das
sieht auch total schön aus, wenn man die
Beetränder mit Kräutern bepflanzt.
Dann gibt es noch eine ganz tolle Pflanze,
die gegen Blattläuse hilft, das ist die Kapuzinerkresse.
Die wirkt zwar nicht so wie die Kräuter,
indem sie Duft verströmt, der Blattläuse
abschreckt, sondern die ist ein wahrer Blattlausmagnet.
Und ich habe das ganz oft in meinem Garten
erlebt, dass wir nur an der Kapuzinerkresse
Blattläuse hatten, weil die sich alle da
draufgestürzt haben.
Das war dann sozusagen die Opferpflanze und
die restlichen Pflanzen wurden verschont.
Also auf jeden Fall ein tolles Zeug.
Ich meine, die Kapuzinerkresseblüten kann
man ja auch wunderbar in den Salat packen,
das ist eine super schöne Pflanze, aber sie
hat eben auch diesen wundervollen Effekt,
dass sie die Blattläuse von dem anderen Gemüse
oder von den anderen Pflanzen abhängt.
Ja, aber was, wenn jetzt schon super viele
Blattläuse an deinen Pflanzen sitzen und
du brauchst jetzt verdammt noch mal einen
Tipp, Marie!
Was man jetzt unternehmen kann, wenn es denn
schon zu spät ist, wenn keine Nützlinge
in Sicht sind und die Beete jetzt einfach
befallen sind und man muss jetzt was unternehmen?
Da will ich dir einmal empfehlen, eine Schmierseifenlösung
anzusetzen.
Das ist ganz einfach gemacht.
Du nimmst einfach einen Liter Wasser, packst
da ungefähr 25 Gramm Schmierseife rein, vermischst
das ordentlich und dann sprühst du das auf
die Pflanzen drauf, direkt auf die Blattläuse.
Und das wiederholst du dann alle paar Tage.
Da solltest du schon super gute Erfolge sehen.
Dann gibt es noch einen vierten Trick, der
funktioniert sehr ähnlich.
Du kannst auch Pflanzenjauchen ansetzen, einfach
eine Brennnesseljauche, ist ja auch ein toller
Dünger, sollte man eh zur Hand haben, stinkt
aber ein bisschen.
Aber, kleiner Tipp, da einfach ein bisschen
Urgesteinsmehl mit reingeben, dann ist das
schon viel, ja, verträglicher, gerade, wenn
man Nachbarn hat, die vielleicht ein bisschen
empfindlich sind.
Ich hatte in meinem allerersten Garten immer
wahnsinnig Skrupel, Brennnesseljauche anzusetzen,
weil ich immer Angst hatte, dass wir irgendwann
da richtig Ärger deswegen kriegen.
Aber seit ich da Urgesteinsmehl reinmache,
hat sich auf jeden Fall noch niemand beschwert
und ich finde es auch viel angenehmer, dann
damit zu arbeiten.
Die Sache ist nur, wenn man Pflanzen mit Jauche
besprüht, dann ist das für die Pflanzen
ziemlich heftig.
Also Jauche ist schon ein krasses Zeug, deswegen
wollen wir eine sehr, sehr junge Jauche ansetzen.
Da nimmst du pro Liter Wasser hundert Gramm
Brennnesseln.
Die packst du da rein, lässt sie über Nacht
in dem Wasser ziehen, dann siebst du das ab.
Und dann kannst du diese Brühe, ich weiß
nicht, ob man es jetzt schon Jauche nennen
kann, diesen Kaltwasserauszug, kannst du dann
unverdünnt auf deine Pflanzen sprühen, aber
nicht länger ziehen lassen, denn dann müsstest
du es schon noch stärker verdünnen beziehungsweise
eignet sich das dann nicht mehr so toll, um
das dann wirklich auf die Pflanzen zu sprühen.
Also da besser nur eine ganz junge Jauche
verwenden.
Ist auch toll, wenn man nicht so lange warten
muss, oder?
Du setzt es an einem Tag an, dann kannst du
am nächsten Tag schon loslegen und deine
Blattläuse damit zum „Donnertrümmel“
jagen.
Das wiederholst du dann alle paar Tage, einfach
immer wieder direkt auf die Blattläuse sprühen
und dann solltest du schon nach spätestens
einer Woche die ersten Erfolge sehen beziehungsweise
schon so gut wie blattlausfreie Pflanzen haben.
Ein ganz blattlausfreier Garten wäre jetzt,
finde ich, nicht so erstrebenswert.
Die gehören, wie gesagt, einfach dazu.
Die haben auch ihre Berechtigung.
Aber wenn sie in Massen auftreten, wenn man
das Gemüse auch nicht mehr essen mag, weil
überall die blöden Blattläuse draufsitzen,
dann ist es schon Zeit, etwas zu unternehmen.
Und da würde ich dir diese beiden Sachen
auf jeden Fall empfehlen, um schnell wirkend,
akut, etwas gegen deinen Blattlausbefall zu
unternehmen.
Ihr habt bestimmt noch ganz viele andere Tricks,
die bei euch gegen Blattläuse geholfen haben.
Da bin ich immer ganz gespannt.
Und ich denke, die anderen Zuschauer freuen
sich auch total, da einmal von euch zu hören.
Also lasst gerne einen Kommentar da und erzählt
mir einmal, was ihr gegen eure Blattläuse
unternehmt und was bei euch gut geholfen hat.
Ich hoffe, das Video hat euch gefallen und
weitergeholfen, eurer Blattlausplage Herr
zu werden.
Wenn euch das Video gefallen hat, dann lasst
gerne einen Daumen nach oben da.
Das hilft mir und meinem Kanal ungemein weiter.
Wenn ihr rund um das Jahr mit Gartentipps
versorgt werden wollt, dann abonniert den
Kanal.
Wir sprechen hier ganz viel über das Thema
Gemüsegarten.
Jetzt steht ja auch bald die Haltbarmachsaison
an, da kommen jetzt auch ganz viele spannende
Videos.
Also drückt den Abo-Button und auch die Glocke,
damit ihr informiert werdet, wenn ein neues
Video erscheint.
Ich poste hier immer samstags um 10 Uhr ein
neues Video.
Ich freue mich, wenn du nächste Woche wieder
mit dabei bist.
Bis dann, mach es gut, tschüss!
Jetzt, das ist eine dumme Überleitung.
Ist der Bildausschnitt überhaupt gut oder
bin ich nicht ein bisschen klein?
…und wollt einfach nur wissen… Huch, Marie,
nicht immer alles abreißen.
Fliegen, Gallmüppen, Gallmücken, Gallmüppen,
Gallmücken, nochmal.
Es ist
so unglaublich gemütlich im Gewächshaus,
wenn es draußen regnet, ich will überhaupt
nicht gehen, aber dabei bin ich schon lange
fertig mit meinem Video.
Vielleicht sollte ich noch ein paar Tomaten
ausgeizen?
Einfach nur, damit ich noch ein bisschen hier
blieben kann.